I have a message for you to send to your Trumpist
friends.
The stock market was better under president
Barack Obama.
Now I want to be careful.
The stock market is not the be all end all
indicator of how the economy is doing for
the average person.
In fact, it's, it's often the opposite.
When stocks soar and wages stay flat, that's
how inequality worsens and further concentrates
at the top.
And we need to look at a whole bunch of different
indicators to really figure out how the economy
is or is not working for the average person,
but Trumpists and Trump himself have hung
their hats on.
The stock market is how we prove that Trump
is winning and that we're doing super well,
so let's do it by their standard.
Now, there's no doubt the stock market has
performed well under Donald Trump, but so
far we're about three years into Donald Trump's
first term, almost to the day it's not performing
as well as it did during Barack Obama's first
three years.
And the great thing about this topic is that
it's very cut and dry.
We have the numbers at this point in time
during the first 36 months of each of their
presidencies, the S and P 500 index, this
is the broadest stock market index of the
big three down NASDAQ andS and P 500 the S
and P 500 was up 59% under Barack Obama and
46% under Donald Trump.
This means that during their first three respective
years, stocks returned about 28% more, 28%
not 28 percentage points.
Please don't email me with math, Amazon misunderstandings.
The stock market returns 28% more during Obama's
first three years than Trump's first three
years during the same time period.
Just as a reference, stocks lost 17% under
George W. Bush.
So what is important here?
What's important is that by the metric Trump
chooses, Barack Obama did better.
Is this the best measure?
No.
Is this the most reflective measure of the
economy at large?
No.
The stock market performance.
Tell us how the middle-class is doing.
No, no, no.
It's, the answer is no to all of these questions,
but it is Trump's metric and Trump is promoting
it and his followers fall for it.
I could show you any of a dozen, uh, more
tweets recently about the stock market.
Here's one from this weekend where Donald
Trump tweeted, if you listened to the flawed
advice of Paul Krugman at the New York times
and newspaper that was going broke until I
came along, you would have entirely missed
the record breaking stock market and other
numbers produced since election day 2016 sorry,
those are the facts.
Unfortunately, no, there is no record.
The stock market performed better under Obama
stock market growth has slowed down under
Donald Trump.
Now let's do the more important analysis.
The more important analysis is Trump continues
to Gaslight his followers, neither the stock
market growth under Obama nor Trump has been
that notable for the tens of millions of Donald
Trump's followers who don't own any or barely
any shares of stock anyway and are very much
like the 2010 tea party movement.
They are cheerleading policies and ideas and
a record that is beneficial to other people,
but not to them.
This is not anything new in politics, particularly
American right wing politics, but let's be
thorough.
Trumpists once presented with these numbers
are going to trot out some pretty predictable
talking points.
For example, they will say when you show them
these numbers, well Obama had bigger growth
because he presided over the recovery from
a recession, so it's logical that there's
going to be rebound growth there.
That will be faster.
It's tougher to do what Trump has done, which
is to keep the growth going.
That's a post facto analysis done once they
are called out for lying about Trump has record
stock market growth, but for every single
one of those talking points you can find a
counterpoint.
The reality is that as I've said under democratic
presidents and I say under Republican presidents
cause and effect with gas prices cause and
effect with the stock market and presidential
policy is difficult to pin down.
I don't even want to play the game other than
to remind you when your Trumpist friends say
the stock market has grown more than under
any other president under Donald Trump, remind
them stocks Rose more during Barack Obama's
first three years than during Donald Trump's
first three years and if indeed we are heading
towards a recession at some point in the next
one to three years, if there is indeed a Trump
reelection that may result in Donald Trump
presiding over far worse numbers than Barack
Obama.
I don't hope that's the case.
I'm not predicting it any more than just every
day we are closer to the next downturn.
That's the way our system of booms and busts
works, but that indeed may happen and then
this won't even be anything that they're talking
about.
You will hear nothing else about the stock
market if and when that crash takes place
in the interim, numbers were better under
Barack Obama than
under Donald Trump.